I have to tell you, Michael Bloomberg is doing
something absolutely hilarious because it
shows how easily triggerable Donald Trump
is.
Michael Bloomberg is trolling Donald Trump
about his weight and remember that this is
something Trump is very triggerable about
by all serious accounts.
Donald Trump is clinically obese now.
He officially claims to be six foot three
inches tall and weigh 239 pounds if true,
that puts them like a pound below clinically
obese, but nobody believes that height.
Trump is pictured in a net in a number of
pictures.
He standing next to people known to be shorter
than six three and Trump is very clearly shorter
than them.
So we know this is a very sensitive topic
for Donald Trump, the alpha male.
This is an ad that Michael Bloomberg put together
where he specifically uses what are known
as fat pics of Donald Trump playing golf.
Now I'm not calling them fat pics pejoratively.
These are specific pictures of Donald Trump
playing golf in like an all white, a very
light khakis and a white shirt where he is
known to be absolutely furious when these
pictures are used because okay, he looks extremely
large in them and Trump doesn't like looking
this way.
Check it out.
It even includes a picture of Trump looking
visibly exhausted and sort of climbing to
reach what looks like an errant golf ball
that he shot, uh, off the course.
Take a look.
People have said when you were mayor, the
city gave Trump a contract to operate a golf
course.
Yes, that's true.
But he was the only bitter and running a golf
course is the only job that I would hire him
for.
I'm my cologne Berg and I approve this message.
It is now being reported by Charlie Gasper
Reno, no left-wing bomb thrower.
He's a reporter for box Fox business network
that the Bloomberg ads with the so called
fat pics have made Trump furious and that
he's been melting down privately and also
tweeting endlessly about Michael Bloomberg,
who he has dubbed Minnie Mike Trump tweeting
in close succession quote.
Many.
Mike is part of the fake news.
They are all working together.
In fact, Bloomberg isn't covering himself
too boring to do or other Dems only Trump.
That sounds fair.
It's all the fake news media and that's why
nobody believes in them anymore.
Continuing to focus on Minnie Mike saying
quote, many of the ads you are watching were
paid for by Minnie Mike Bloomberg.
He is going nowhere just wasting his money
but he is getting the DNC to rig the election
against crazy Bernie something they wouldn't
do for Cory Booker and others.
They are going to do it again to Bernie 2016
and then once again and this one is actually
hilarious.
Trump tweeting so triggered many.
Mike is now negotiating both to get on the
Democrat primary debate stage and to have
the right to stand on boxes or a lift during
the debates.
This is sometimes but not really fair.
That is absolutely hilarious.
This stuff Trump comes up with when he gets
triggered is so funny.
He also did something Trump did that he rarely
does if ever, which is he tweeted about exercising.
Now remember, Donald Trump is the guy who
believes that when the human body exercises,
it depletes some total amount of energy that
you have at your disposal for life.
And so he's not a guy who brags about exercising.
And yet after the fat pic ad came out, Donald
Trump tweeting a picture of himself golfing
with a caption, getting a little exercise
this morning.
So regardless of Bloomberg's chances and the
chances aren't great, although I do believe
it's possible, Mike Bloomberg could end up
third in delegates, one if he continues the
strategy that we've outlined a couple of weeks
ago.
This is just fantastic.
I would love to see Bloomberg also do some
ads that are compilations of Trump's slurred
speech.
You know, the United States of America, God
bless the USA, the Israeli city of Jerusalem,
and that, that type of thing.
Whoever is doing these knows exactly what
the trigger points are for Donald Trump and
his exploiting them.
I saw that the Bloomberg campaign is hiring
some data science people here in Massachusetts,
probably another super Tuesday States as well.
Clearly Bloomberg is not being shy about laying
out the cash and we can expect a lot of action
from Bloomberg.
I just hope there's more of these ads that
are triggering Trump visibly on Twitter.
Last thing to clarify, I'm not making fun
of obesity, nor do I find it funny.
It's a serious medical condition.
What I'm pointing out is that the supposed
alpha male Trump, who's the best at everything,
both eats a terrible diet, doesn't exercise
and is so easily triggerable when you hit
certain pressure points and Michael Bloomberg
is taking advantage
of those.